in the last video we saw that choice a
is true now let's see if B C and D are
also true so choice B they're telling us
that the argument let me rewrite it over
here I'll do it in another color their
choice B is telling us that the argument
the argument of Z minus Z 1 is equal to
the argument of Z minus Z 2 now let's
think about this a little bit
we already did some work we simplified
what Z minus Z 1 is equal to it's equal
to T T times z2 minus z1 so this is
equivalent to saying that the argument
the argument of T times z2 minus z1 I'm
just leveraging some of the algebra that
we already did because this thing is the
same thing as what's inside of the
absolute value sign which is the same
thing as this thing over here so the
argument is T times z2 minus z1 is equal
to so I'm just rewriting statement be
the statement V is just saying that this
should be equal to the argument of now
what's Z minus Z 2 Z minus z2 we figured
out we figured out was this thing over
here actually let's say it's this thing
right over here it's equal to this thing
right over here and we could rewrite we
could rewrite this thing as being equal
to running out of real estate here but
we could rewrite this thing right here
is being equal to 1 minus T as being
equal to 1 minus T I'm just factoring
out the 1 minus T times z1 time times Z
1 Z 1 minus Z 2 Z 1 minus Z 2 or so we
can get it in the same form here let's
multiply well let's multiply this times
negative 1 and this times negative 1 so
I'm multiplying by negative 1 twice so
I'm not changing the number so this is
going to be equal to or the statement is
claiming this is equal to the argument
of t minus 1 t minus 1 let me write a
little bit neater than that so the claim
is that this should be equal to the
argument of t minus 1
t minus 1 times Z 2 minus Z 1 so let's
think about this and just remember all I
did here is I multiplied this by
negative 1 and this by negative 1 if I
multiply two things times negative 1
it's equivalent to multiplying by
negative 1 twice which is just
multiplying it by 1 so I was able to
swap both of these so is this true is it
true that the argument of T times z2
minus z1 is it true that that's the same
thing as the argument of t minus 1 times
z2 minus z1 so let's just think about it
a little bit let's draw an Argand
diagram let's draw an Argand diagram
here that's the imaginary axis this is
the real axis and let's draw the vector
z2 minus z1
so let's say that this right here is the
vector let me draw it like this this
right here is the vector z2 minus z1
now what would T times z2 minus z1 look
like so T we learned is between 0 & 1 so
it's going to be a scaled down version
of z2 minus z1 so this right here so who
knows what it is this right here would
be T times z2 minus z1
now what would t minus 1 times z2 minus
z1 look like well t minus 1 remember T
is between 0 & 1 so T is less than 1 so
t minus 1 this right here is going to be
a negative number it's going to be a
negative number so it's going to be
we're going to be scaling it by a
negative number so we're going to be
scaling z2 minus z1 by a negative number
so this thing right over here this thing
right over here t minus 1 times z2 minus
z1 is going to look like this it's going
to look like this this is t minus 1 t
minus 1 times z2 minus z1 now the
arguments the arguments are just the
angles between the each of these numbers
and the real axis so the argument for
this thing right over here is going to
be this angle it's going to be
it's going to be five right over here so
I could call that I could call that Phi
but what's the argument for this thing
it's going to be that plus PI or plus
180 degrees we have to go all the way
around we have to go all the way around
so they are not the same angle whatever
whatever number this is right over here
this number is going to be that plus
plus PI or even minus PI you can even go
that way but they're definitely not
going to be the same angle so we can
cross out we can cross out choice B
choice B as an option but now that we're
in this mode let's see if we can tackle
choice D because it looks very similar
and then I'll probably do choice C in
the next video because I want I don't
want to spend too much time in each
video so what is choice D telling us let
me write it down here
choice D is telling us so we don't know
we have to see if it's true that the
argument of Z minus z1 is equal to the
argument is equal to the argument of z2
minus z1
so let's think a little bit about let's
think a little bit about this right now
so once again we they tell us we already
figured out what Z minus z1 is equal to
it's equal to this business over here so
this statement is equivalent to the
statement that the argument of of Z
minus z1 which is T times z2 minus z1
leveraging our algebra in the last video
T times z2 minus z1 is this equal to the
argument of z2 minus z1
well once again let's draw our Argand
diagram here we can even leverage
actually we can leverage the same Argand
diagram in green in green right here we
have z2 minus z1 this it's argument
would be this angle right over here it
would be it would be this angle Phi this
is z2 minus z1 that's that angle T times
z2 minus z1 is just going to be the
scaled down version of it what we have
in orange now clearly this is just T is
positive so it's not pointing in another
direction this
just a scaled-down version of this this
vector and this vector or this complex
number and this complex number we're
going to point in the same direction so
their angles are the same T let me do it
this orange vector is this right over
here or that orange complex number is
this right over here this is T times z2
minus z1 and then the green one just to
be clear z2 minus z1 is that they're
clearly in the same direction they
clearly have the same argument so choice
D so choice D is another correct choice
is another correct choice
now I'm going to leave you there in the
next video we're going to see if choice
C works